[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité
avec elle à une cette semaine les prix
de l'énergie au coeur des préoccupations
des territoires au baisser la facture
les collectivités font la chasse au
moindre gaspillage énergétique notamment
dans la loire comme le montrera t elle
cette dans les yvelines un bâtiment est
quant à lui chauffer grâce à la chaleur
de la route
explications de tv 78 à suivre l'accueil
des réfugiés ukrainien aussi dans ce
journal dans la haute garonne un
adolescent et sa mère se construisent
progressivement un nouveau quotidien
loin des bombardements à reportage de
via occitanie à découvrir dans cette
édition dans un instant en bretagne la
chaîne tv air nous emmènera sur un
chantier naval pas comme les autres
celui d'un voilier historique la remise
à l'eau est pour bientôt grâce notamment
au travail de bénévoles et puis ici vous
êtes en appétit ce reportage et pour
vous enfin d'édition les rillettes du
mans seront mises à l'honneur nouveau
record du plus long sandwich oreillettes
vient d'être battue plus de 101 m de
quoi casser la croûte à plusieurs avec
ce reportage de lmtv dans la sarthe bien
sûr
voilà il est des 1er avril meilleures
que d'autres depuis vendredi les
automobilistes peuvent profiter de la
remise carburant annoncée il ya quelques
semaines par le premier ministre une
remise qui peut atteindre 18 centimes
par litre d'essence en france
métropolitaine un soulagement pour de
nombreux particuliers et professionnels
alors que les coûts de l'énergie
s'envolent depuis le début de la guerre
en ukraine les collectivités sont elles
aussi impactés et dans la loire par
exemple le maire de la commune de la
roche molière a vu sa facture augmenter
de 17 mille euros au mois de février un
surcoût difficile à absorber pour la
commune pour faire la chasse aux
économies le maire a donc décidé de
passer à l'action et traquent le moindre
geste énergivores
quarante mille mètres carrés de
bâtiments publics doivent être chauffée
écoutez son témoignage au micro de
céline ersilia pour la chaîne tl7 enfin
après toutes les portes de partout où on
l'a mis tous les bâtiments communaux
surtout les gymnases les stades les
écoles de partout et je passe aussi de
façon aléatoire partout tout le temps et
c'est énervant ch un peu le père
fouettard des économies mais en même
temps quand on rend sur les notes et un
c'est comme à la maison non mes enfants
je leur dit de fermer les portes et
d'éteindre les lumières parce que c'est
papa qui paye les notes et là c'est le
maire qui paye les notes qui gère le
budget de la commune et voilà il faut il
faut est un des lumières et fermer les
portes qu'est ce qui nous permet de
faire des économies
voilà des gestes simples que chacun
d'entre nous essaie d'appliquer au
quotidien zoom à présent sur une autre
initiative technologique celle ci dans
les yvelines une entreprise travaille
depuis quelques années au développement
d'un système de chauffage rendue
possible grâce à la route là près du
péage de saint-arnoult dans les yvelines
chaleur du soleil et voiture sur la
chaussée permettent de chauffer un
bâtiment une invention étonnante écoutez
les précisions au micro de céline
charles de tv 78 la chaîne des yvelines
l'été les routes vont chauffer leurs
vêtements va monter en température
environ 60 degrés donc en fait on a eu
l'idée de mettre dans la deuxième couche
de la route des tubes des tubes dans
lequel on va faire circuler un fluide
caloporteur va le faire passer dans les
sondes géothermiques on va augmenter la
température naturel de la terre qui nous
entoure de 15 degrés ça c'est l'été et
quand on a besoin l'hiver donc de
chauffer un bâtiment des logements une
piscine en gymnase à ce moment là on va
utiliser on va extraire les calories qui
sont dans ce volume de termes concernés
par les sondes géothermiques awake frère
avec des pompes à chaleur d'une manière
classique pour chauffer tous ces
équipements
les prix de l'énergie vous le savez qui
sont indexés ces dernières semaines sur
la situation en ukraine côté humain de
nombreux habitants continuent de fuir le
pays pour échapper aux bombardements et
tentent de se réfugier un peu partout en
europe pour ceux déjà arrivés l'enjeu
est désormais de trouver leur place dans
leur nouveau lieu de vie et d'essayer de
reconstruire un quotidien en haute
garonne une habitante accueille un jeune
et sa mère depuis plus d'une semaine la
vie à trois s'organise avec le temps et
la bienveillance un reportage d'anne a
argué pour vyas occitane et des poches
remplies de vêtements chaque jour
frédéric reçoit la visite lider de ses
proches ou de la mairie de bessières
contribuant à l'accueil de deux
ukrainiens chez elle alexandre saison et
sa mère nina 62 ans sont arrivés dans la
nuit de mardi presque les mains vides
sont arrivés avec une valise pour deux
c'était vraiment l'urgence un pour lui
trouver pour leur trouver des avis
depuis trois jours alexandre et nina
s'acclimate au quotidien de frédéric
très reconnaissant d'avoir pu échapper à
la guerre
quand nous sommes arrivés à bessières
nous avons rencontré frédéric et phyllis
nous sommes installés dans leur maison
et je pense qu'en fin aujourd'hui en
sécurité je suis très reconnaissante
toutes les aides que nous avons reçues
autrement mais l'adaptation prend du
temps et passe par la communication
nina et alexandre ne parle ni français
ni anglais frédéric utilisent des
traducteurs sur son téléphone et a
inventé en manuels d'apprentissage qui
l'utilisent tous les jours là des
petites des petites étiquettes et à
chaque fois il y a bon le
le mot en français en ukrainien et la
prononciation en fait qui va avec
comment t'appelles-tu voilà c'est on en
est vraiment au tout début mais je pense
que c'est le tout début qui est le plus
difficile frédéric s'investit beaucoup
pour rendre le quotidien de nina et son
fils plus facile et plus heureux elle a
réservé sa semaine en attendant qu'ils
gagnent en autonomie
voilà on referme cette page consacrée à
la guerre en ukraine avec un extrait de
l'émission face aux territoires diffusé
jeudi dernier sur tv5 monde vadim
omeltchenko l'ambassadeur d'ukraine en
france était l'invité de ce numéro
spécial consacré à la guerre dans son
pays regardez ce qu'a dit ce proche de
volodymyr zen ce qui le président
ukrainien la croix rouge fait l'objet
d'une campagne de dénigrement sur les
réseaux sociaux accusés d'avoir pris
part à l'évacuation forcée de civils
vers vers la russie ces accusations sont
injustifiées il y en à vos coordonnées
signifiant qu'une attaque pourquoi je ne
voyons pas près des villes assiégées
qu'est ce que tout un chacun nous avons
été élevés j'étais l'enfance
sur le fait que la croix rouge est
présente là où il ya besoin là où il ya
la guerre la dessiccation est
catastrophique et c'est pour cela que la
croix rouge bénéficie d'une immunité
cela permet d'agir dans les situations
où les deux parties ne peuvent pas agir
est donc j'ai posé la question pourquoi
nous vous n'allez pas danser en liant
n'organisait pas aller couloir
humanitaire dans les villes de ces
sujets par exemple la mare chicose et la
réponse était puisque la russie ne
reconnais par notre immunité et nous
avons tous peur qu'ils nous attaquent
j'ai dit et
votre déclaration publique à ce sujet
pourquoi vous ne dites pas au monde
entier que la russie ne reconnaît pas
votre immunité
voilà les missions face au territoire et
à voir ou à revoir sur les sites
internet de tv5monde en repli sur ouest
france.fr sur nicematin.com et sur
20minutes.fr
les partenaires de face aux territoires
dans le reste de l'actualité une
initiative pour l'insertion dans les
vosges la sncf y propose à titre
expérimental bien sûr et en lien
l'institution judiciaire des travaux
d'intérêts généraux en contact direct
avec les voyageurs des missions qui
peuvent déboucher sur un emploi à plein
temps pour les condamnés à de courtes
peines une équipe de vosges télévision
s'est intéressé à ce dispositif en garde
epinal certains visages sont bien
entendu shooter reportage d'anthony
saper et dan didier sur place
un job provisoires non rémunéré une
mission de quelques dizaines d'heures
pour éviter de passer par la case prison
c'est le principe du travail d'intérêt
général réservé à ceux qui n'ont commis
que des petits délits et dégradations
des outrages
certaines petites violences ou
incivilités le fait de pas payer
également le lait les billets de train
aussi peut rentrer dans c dans les tiges
le tiche existe depuis les années 80
mais il a tendance aujourd'hui à évoluer
là où les missions consistaient surtout
jusqu'ici à nettoyer des tags ou
ramasser des déchets en bord de route
la sncf dans le grand-est tente une
autre approche des personnes récemment
condamné par la justice sont en contact
direct avec les voyageurs pour les
guider les informer et aussi lutter
contre la fraude ils sont à l'accueil
embarquement et c'est une première en
france
on a une cinquantaine d'heures
effectuées à la gare d'epinal à notre
mission c'est d'accueillir les gens qui
prennent le train de contrôler le type
d'embarquement en fait c'est comme une
formation un peu près une centrale nous
formulons parce que oui la sncf pourrait
très bien au final embauché l'un d'entre
eux ou leurs commandes et à une autre
entreprise voyant notre conviction c'est
qu'en fait ce genre d'accueil
embarquement ça permet de lutter contre
la récidive des gens qui ont été
condamnés à des peines et nous avons
formé nos agents pour pouvoir les
encadrer et ensuite pourquoi pas s'il si
l'accueil se passe bien en général
pendant six mois les embaucher en af
embaucher 1 l'année dernière à
thionville et l'histoire pourrait très
bien se finir ici aussi puisque si la
sncf est satisfaite des tiges au service
du public dans le grand est elle
pourrait rapidement développer
l'expérience dans d'autres régions de
france
comment lutter contre le dépôt des
déchets sauvages la question tracasse
les maires et les collectivités dans
toute la france face aux incivilités de
certains de ses administrés un élu de
l'aube a eu l'idée originale d'afficher
les déchets dans toute la ville oui vous
avez bien entendu une exposition de
vieilles télévisions usagers de chaises
et autres objets a envahi les rues de la
commune de sainte savine objectif de
l'opération sensibiliser la population
chaque mois les services municipaux
ramassent deux tonnes et demie de
déchets et encombrants beaucoup trop
pour le maire écoutez le au micro de nos
partenaires de l'est éclair
c'est une exposition
ce que l'on retrouve en fait sur la voie
publique en termes de dépôts sauvages
sur le territoire de sainte savine donc
l'idée c'était de pouvoir
représenter et montrer ce qu'on pouvait
collectées sur une période d'un mois sur
le territoire de sainte savine donc une
représentation sur différents points
pour montrer bas tout ce qu'on peut
retrouver que ce soit des réfrigérateurs
des canapés
des parapluies fin à tous les types de
déchets qu'on retrouve en tant que
dépôts sauvages sur le sur le territoire
voilà une idée qui on l'espère fera
changer les mentalités et les
comportements
en corse les collectivités et c'est
aussi de réduire l'impact des ordures
sur l'environnement et de mobiliser leur
population
dans le port de calvi la mairie et
l'intercommunalité viennent d'installer
un filet anti déchets pour empêcher que
les eaux depuis transforme la mer en
poubelle géante le principe est simple
stoppez les bouteilles en plastique et
autres détritus avant qu'il ne soit
rejetée dans la mer précision à l'image
de benjamin kanak et d'andorre si ni de
la rédaction de via télé pas aisée on
fait principalement et barrage flottant
anti pollution et des menaces anti macro
déchets comme on vient de s'installer
aujourd'hui ça consiste à stopper les
déchets avant qu'il ne rejoigne le
milieu naturel les études ont montré que
80% des déchets arrivent de part la
terre et sont générés par l'homme et
rejoignent via le réseau d'eaux
pluviales les mers et les océans et on
peut très difficilement voir c'est même
quasiment impossible de nettoyer les les
mers et les océans une fois que ces
déchets rejoint ses avantages ils sont
nombreux lors de sa conception nous
avons voulu trouver une solution qui
soit simple efficace sans électricité
bien sûr pour qu'on reste dans la
logique et qui permettent de fonctionner
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
sans transition dans ce grand jt des
territoires direction désormais le val
d'oise à présent où la commune de
franconville propose depuis deux ans un
atelier d'initiation aux échecs pour
tous les élèves de cm1 cette initiative
qui émane d'un rapport du ministère de
l'éducation nationale
se base sur le recours à certains jeux
tels que les échecs pour améliorer le
niveau des élèves en mathématiques un
moyen d'apprentissage ludique et
concrets pour les écoliers qui semble
fonctionner vous allez le voir au
portage d'elisa un état pour vyas 95
donc dans le val d'oise
stéphane pensons professeur d'échec
apprend à cette classe de cm1 à jouer à
ce jeu de stratégie
un apprentissage qui leur permet
d'évoluer sur le plan personnel il n'ya
pas nécessairement pré requis donc même
en ayant certaines difficultés dans les
disciplines scolaires traditionnels ils
vont pouvoir s'est rapidement se rendre
compte qu ils sont capables et gagner en
confiance et puis ce match soudain
s'exprimer poser des questions
participer là où ils ne le font pas
nécessairement sur la toute première
séance loin des cahiers de mathématiques
et de français ses élèves de
franconville exécute dans la bonne
humeur les stratégies de ce jeu de
logique j'aime bien les films parce que
ça fait réfléchir le cerveau on peut
s'amuser avec ses amis en même temps
proposé pendant une dizaine d'années sur
la pause méridienne pour les élèves
volontaires
l'ensemble des ces aimants de
franconville bénéficient de cours
d'échecs obligatoire depuis deux ans ce
dispositif découle d'un rapport de
l'éducation nationale par mois en
février 2018 il alerte la dégradation
des résultats des élèves dans cette
matière le gouvernement préconise entre
autres la pratique de certains jeux tels
que les échecs pour améliorer le niveau
des élèves en mathématiques se repérer
dans l'espace
au niveau des stratégies pour réussir à
à bouger les pieds c'est en mettre en
échec en fait son adversaire dix séances
sont prévues dans l'année pour le moment
à peine la moitié des cessions a été
réalisée
c'est peut-être un peu tôt pour voir un
apport sur leur comportement peut être
un petit peu plus quand même de contrôle
de soi dans l'excitation dans
l'énervement et dans la frustration
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur perdre une
partie une chose comme ça faire de ce
projet la municipalité de franconville
aimerait aller encore plus loin et
organiser un tournoi avec l'ensemble des
ses mains de la ville l'année prochaine
des classes du primaire aux études
supérieures découvrant à présent le
parcours de florent un jeune limougeaud
passionné d'aviation est étudiant en
informatique
il pilote depuis sa majorité un avion de
tourisme et rêvent plus tard de prendre
les commandes d'un avion de ligne pour
florent apprendre à piloter ce n'est pas
qu'une idée en l'air c'est le cas de le
dire reportage d'alain druot pour 7 à
limoges
un peu avant 18 ans on rêve de se
déplacer en autonomie avec son permis de
conduire pour florent ces conduites et
pilotage j'ai la chance de faire un
baptême de l'air il ya à peu près dix
ans et puis le soir même j'ai acheté un
simulateur de vol et puis bah ça s'est
jamais arrêtée et étudiant en
informatique le jeune pilote accumulent
les heures de vol à l'héro club avec en
ligne de mire l'école de l'aviation
civile on apprend toute la partie avion
qu'on n'a pas en simulateur dole ce
qu'on n'est pas sûr qu'on n'est pas si
rare et avions donc forcément c'est un
petit peu spéciale de passer d'une vague
du virtuel au réel et surtout
l'apprentissage des perspectives de 2
comment commencer un avion se comporte
dans l'air et on a tout l'aérologie qui
est vachement différentes un simulateur
de vol ne reproduit pas la réalité il
essaye de reproduire la réalité il ya
une grande différence entre le
simulateur est réel il répondit hôtel
bonjour monsieur fox et le col del teil
hôtel un cessna 172 au parking avec
charlie de personnes à bord en fait on
les pointe de l'île prêts à décoller
concentré florent laisse cinq secondes
son esprit se projeter dans le futur
le dit c'est la consécration
devant ce pilote développeurs
informatiques se présente un cursus
quasi complet pour le futur commandant
d'or entre maintenant et le 2e ligne
mois ce qui va surtout
s'est passé ça va être comment va
évoluer l'aviation ce que l'aviation
sont un petit peu de mal donc il n'y a
pas de perspective d'emploi il faut
compter deux ans pour être professionnel
je part pas de zéro donc j'ai quand même
quelques heures déjà vu dans l'immédiat
florent et dans l'attenté de la
confirmation de sa participation cet été
au tour aérien des jeunes pilotes
tout à fait autre chose maintenant
destination mars au départ de toulouse
dans cette édition un terrain martien
vient d'être inauguré à la cité de
l'espace là bas une première en europe
ce cratère accueille les répliques en
taille réelle des robots présents
actuellement sur la planète rouge
persévérance ezio ronde c'est leur nom
cet équipement a été conçu en
partenariat avec le centre national
d'études spatiales et sera ouvert au
public dès ce 5 avril une plongée sur
masse depuis la terre les précisions
recueillies par manon aussi pour le
journal la dépêche du midi nos
partenaires on a une idée parce que mars
l'exploration robotique de la planète
est une actualité qui va nous amener
jusqu'à 2030 trois avec une grande
aventure de retour d'échantillons
martiens sur terre donc nous on a voulu
doter à la cité de l'espace d'un écrin
martiens de ce cratère pour pouvoir
raconter cette super aventure à nos
visiteurs sur les dix ans à venir on
peut dire qu'on propose une animation
immersive dans des conditions réelles
voilà d'un voyage dans l'espace à une
aventure sur l'eau près de saint malo 1
voiliers historiques est actuellement en
pleine rénovation le caire mort c'est
son nom est en chantier pour quelques
semaines encore après un temps passé à
l'abandon sur le littoral bientôt il
reprendra la mer grâce à l'engagement
d'une association et le travail de
jeunes de la protection de l'enfance une
remise à neuf et à l'eau pas comme les
autres que nous raconte claudia kara
tories pour la chaîne tv air à rennes
c'est l'histoire d'un vieux gréement à
l'abandon sur les bords de la rance
construit en 1951 à camaret kermor ce
voilier classé bateau d'intérêt
patrimonial a été repéré par
l'association malouine sensation
littoral acheté un euro symbolique à son
propriétaire il est à présent en
chantier applaudir entre les mains
expertes de camille gaboriau charpentier
de marine c'est vrai que c'est
passionnant travail j'ai travaillé sur
un beau bateau donc en plus l'utilité de
ce bateau dans l'avenir tel qu'on m'a
expliqué c'est le bateau typique de ce
que ce que l'armateur recherchait à ses
côtés un bel équipage sont apprentis des
bénévoles de l'association et des jeunes
de la protection de l'enfance se
relaient pour donner une nouvelle vie à
ce bateau de pêche c'est simplement le
bois qui va absorber tout le produit
qu'on lui mais c'est pas du vernis
chantier de bateaux oui ils l'ont vu au
tout début il ongles arriver le bateau
ils ont vu se construire les espars donc
les mâles et beau milieu vergues ça
aujourd'hui participent à leur
confection et alors lisa sion et le but
du jeu est évidemment c'est qu'ils
montent dessus une fois qu'il aura 2
sera bientôt le kermor rejoindra la
flotte des voiliers de l'association
sensation littoral vous fait de la
découverte aussi bien à terre qu'en mer
du patrimoine marin du patrimoine du
littoral et notamment aussi de la côte
d'émeraude donc le fait d'avoir en fait
ce jeu gré manqué magnifique le caire
mort ça nous permettra d'aller
d'accueillir le maximum de personnes
chaque personne participe aux manoeuvres
du bateau aussi bien diriger le bateau
que sortir les voiles etc il reste
encore du travail sur le chantier les
bénévoles sont les bienvenus pour que
d'ici quelques semaines le kermor
navigue de nouveau en baie de saint malo
et embarque petits et grands marins à la
barre de ce voilier d'un autre temps
tout à fait autre chose après deux
années de fermeture pour travaux le
restaurant les belles perdrix située à
saint-émilion en gironde s'est vue
distinguée d'une étoile au guide
michelin dans le classement 2022 une
récompense pour sa réouverture a
agrémenté d'une étoile verte pour son
engagement écologique de la cuisine de
qualité et locales et aussi vertueuse
pour l'environnement alix fourcade de
tv7 nous fait découvrir quelques
éléments de cette recette magique
regardez tout commence par le potager
pour le chef david charrier sorte une
carotte vous l'avez vous l'accusez vous
la donner à votre client au niveau
circuits courts et fraîcheur ne pouvait
pas beaucoup faire mieux à quelques
mètres de là son restaurant les belles
perdrix installé au sein du château trop
plomb mon dos à saint-émilion pour ce
potager notamment et s'est vue
distinguée d'une étoile verte par le
guide michelin 2022 cette étoile
récompense les initiatives vertueuse
pour l'environnement et ce qui n'est pas
cuisiner ce sont les animaux qui le
mange s'il solution pour nous
m zéro déchets organiques on garde tous
la propriété est ce qu'on peut pas
recycler on est au compost qui va miser
qui va être utilisé après pour le
potager au restaurant a fermé deux ans
pour travaux il avait une étoile qu'il a
dû rendre à michelin il la récupère
cette année pour la réouverture est
toujours à mes équipes penser que
comme si c'était votre meilleure amie
qui arrivait à la maison votre famille à
la maison si vous avez envie de leur
faire plaisir ce qu'on fait ici mais ses
yeux
des prix avec tous les gens qui viennent
chez nous essayer de refaire passer 1 la
maison son chef pâtissier adrien
salabert a aussi reçu la distinction
passion des serres du michelin on est
dans notre dans notre petite bulle de
laboratoire comme on appelle ici et est
en fait on voit pas trop on n'entend pas
toujours le nord autour des clients et
la deux le fait d'être reconnu par le
guide michelin ça nous fait que ça nous
fait extrêmement plaisir les belles
perdrix est le seul restaurant de la
région à avoir reçu une étoile verte
voilà tout à fait autre chose plus
simple mais tout aussi appétissant le
sandwich oreillettes fait la fierté de
la sarthe au mans le record du plus long
sandwich au monde vient d'être battu 101
m et 43 cm précisément un record pour la
défense de la culture culinaire locale
après s'être fait voler la vedette par
les villes de laval et de tours les
années précédentes mais aussi pour la
bonne cause par portage festif et
convivial d'enzo maubert pour lmtv
sartre bien sûr
record battu 101 m et 43 cm la sarthe a
officiellement réalisé le plus long
sandwich oreillettes du monde et il a
fallu de la place pour l'installer en
plein milieu de l'esplanade des jacobins
à tel point que les organisateurs ont
même dû s'arranger pour laisser passer
les voitures
mais bon que ne ferait on pas pour nos
fameuses rillettes et vraiment attachée
à son patrimoine que sont les rillettes
et un sarthois ressens rien tu n'es pas
à sarthois voilà
des centaines de personnes réunies dans
une ambiance joyeuse on n'avait pas vu
ça depuis bien longtemps
un public heureux pour un défi de taille
et la fallu 50 tartine heures 200
baguette est pas moins de 46 kg de
rillettes pour arriver à ce sandwich
géant une vraie organisation pour une
bonne cause
on est forcément fière way déjà on est
content d'avoir fait le travail en moins
d'une heure et en fait c'est pas un
travail parce que on est tous là les
collègues boucher
boulangers et charcutiers on s'est amusé
à faire le service il fait 101 m mais le
but c'est de l'offrir à quelqu'un donc
là on est en train de le vendre en ce
moment pour une association les ailes du
rire donc pour nous c'est très important
voilà le sens du tout n'est pas à jeter
et le profit c'est uniquement une
association les organisateurs donnent
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour un
nouveau record n'en déplaise aux
lavallois ou aux tourangeaux qui avait
essayé de nous d'être sonné l'arrêté
sarthoise et elle le restera
[Musique]
une idée de sortie culturelle à présent
dans ce grand jt des territoires avec
l'exposition bonjour paris à découvrir
jusqu'au 15 avril dans la capitale
cette exposition présente 29 artistes
internationaux issus de la nouvelle
scène pop asiatique des oeuvres souvent
inspirées de l'univers manga et de l'art
urbain ils sont notamment exposés vous
envoyer quelques images prises par
ariana hierso certains patrons notamment
de hong kong expose pour la première
fois à paris sont donc à découvrir à la
galerie 24b dans le 1er arrondissement
de la capitale enfin d'autres belles
images pour terminer cette édition celle
d'un journaliste de sud ouest jean
michel selva journalistes et
photographes d'ailleurs qui est un
passionné de sa ville bordeaux est des
états unis également en particulier
comme vous le voyez de la nouvelle
orléans où il s'amuse à capter
l'ambiance et les couleur si
particulière de cette ville de bien
beaux clichés qui nous permettent de
voyager de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
le temps de quelques photos voilà c'est
la fin de ce grand jt des territoires
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous très vite dans une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]